Apple's iMac has been iconic in the tech
world for decades but Apple hasn't shown
the larger 27-inch model any love in
almost three years instead focusing on
the new redesigned 24-inch model but we
just got a brand new leak that just
might be the last final missing piece to
the 27-inch iMac Pro puzzle so let's get
started just the other day Ross young
who is a display consultant and very
good with Apple display leaks said that
the rumor 27-inch display with Pro
motion is no longer planned for now
basically canceled for the time being
and then Ming Shaco add it to that leak
from Ross young and said that it is
still planned the mini LED 27-inch
promotion model but mass production is
slated for 2024 to 2025. so people on
Twitter started saying maybe there's
still hope for the 27 inch external
monitor her and rosseng replied he
posted about it just to let everybody
know that it's not coming out wwc or
anytime this year and if they decide to
bring it back it's going to be 2024 or
2025 and we're gonna know about it
before it launches now the reason this
27-inch external display cancellation or
delay is so important is first of all
the timing and also that these display
leaks originally were perceived to be
the actual iMac Pro itself so let me
give you a quick history of all these
leaks and explained how it all comes
together just a couple of months ago in
February Ross young came out and said
that the 27 inch display with many LEDs
has been delayed yet again and the
reason he says yet again is because it's
been delayed a lot check this out back
in July he said it's going to be delayed
until early
2023 and before that in may he said that
it would be delayed until October and
then before that in March of 2022 he
said it would be coming in June as its
own display and the reason he said that
was because in March of 2022 Apple had
an event where they released the studio
display so he changed his mind on the
idea that it could have been an iMac Pro
check this out he said it could launch
in June as an external display and right
here in this tweet he said we were
expecting a 27 inch mini LED from Apple
coming in June and it might be a studio
display Pro and they believe that
production has already started and keep
in mind that was back in
2022 so I asked him has anything changed
in terms of your thoughts on the 27-inch
iMac Pro coming in June and he says it
looks like we might instead have a
studio display Pro instead of the iMac
Pro and he said it could be coming a
alongside a new Mac Pro instead of the
iMac so basically so many leaks and
delays have happened since way back then
and guess what it goes back even further
in February of 2022 he said that it
could be a mini LED iMac Pro launching
in June at WWDC and even before that in
January he said Don't expect it at the
spring event likely in the middle and
even before then in December of 2021
that's when all the leaks started of the
iMac Pro with a mini LED expected in
Spring 2022 so so many leaks have
happened since then even going back all
the way to October the first time that
he started talking about it now there
was this update which is very very
interesting while he initially stated
that it could be a 27 inch mini LED
display as an external monitor he was
now saying it would be for an updated
iMac and then the monitor could come
later that was his original leak and
idea way back in 2021 so here is my
theory what if Ross young was right all
along about this display being destined
for an iMac first before later being
introduced as an external Apple display
because Apple has done that in the past
with their 4K and 5K iMac displays that
were later sold as the LG ultra fine
display line so what if the new 27-inch
iMac Pro comes first and then a year or
two later they introduce it as an
external display that is my idea and if
you're thinking this is all a joke Apple
probably just scrapped the iMac forever
that is actually wrong because last year
in 2022 Apple allegedly prototyped and
tested a redesigned 27-inch iMac with an
M1 Max chip and a black finish that's
back in 2022 and all of that was was
based on Insider information by a Mac
Rumors Forum user amethyst and I
completely trust his Source because he
was the first one in the world to leak
the Mac Studio before the March 2022
Apple event and that he was also right
about the M2 Mac Mini having the same
design with a simple chip swap to the M2
but then also including a new chip which
ended up being the Mt Mac Pro and then
once again he was also right with the
same thing for the MacBook Pros the new
M2 Max and M2 Pro way back on March 10th
2022 amethyst said that he's aware of a
prototype iMac with a 27-inch mini LED
display matching up to exactly what Ross
young has been saying and then on March
11th he even made his own Mac Rumors
Forum post saying that there is
information about a big iMac including
three prototypes that they had the first
one had the same panel as the 2020 27
inch model with an M1 processor then
they had a 24 inch chassis style which
is the redesign with a 24 inch panel and
M1 and then finally they had the same
style redesign in black with an xdr mini
LED 27 inch panel and M1 Max processor
so Apple has been testing it and I fully
trust this source so the good news is
that we do have evidence of Apple
testing a new 27 inch redesigned iMac
with the same design language as the
redesigned 24 inch and with an apple
silicon chip which proves that the large
iMac is not dead apple is simply testing
and prototyping it and figuring out when
to release it so the big question is why
and when to answer why well I believe
it's because Apple released the Max
studio and the studio display combo as
an iMac alternative and they want to
give it some time to simmer and sell
before introduce using a larger iMac Pro
and the last question is when well I
think it's going to be coming with an M3
family based chip probably the M3 Max or
maybe even the M3 Ultra which points at
some time in 2024 and the only reason it
can support the ultra chip with two dies
is because of the super efficient three
nanometer technology from tsmc that
makes sure it's going to be able to keep
it cool and that will be perfect for the
iMac Pro so there you go that's when I
think it's going to be coming and I
think it's going to be coming before
that display and that might be why the
display itself got delayed so thanks for
watching if you have any thoughts let me
know down in the comment section below
click the circle button subscribe for
more videos like this one check out one
of those right there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
foreign
[Music]